[Music]
cody's in cleveland ohio hi cody how are
you
good how you doing better than i deserve
what's up
all right so uh i'm a new listener i
just found you guys today
basically just as
in 26 i've pretty much lived
paycheck to paycheck my whole life uh
and
uh looking at your hearing you guys's
channel so far this morning it's giving
me some kind of ideas to finally get me
out of this this first time i've
actually seen like a way out
so i've got
i've got a total of
forty-two thousand dollars in debt right
now it's just me i have a fiance but
hers is only two thousand dollars in
credit cards i can take care of that
that's not something i'm really worried
about
um
so i have
the only real cost i have is credit
cards and auto loans
so my question is
this morning i got the idea of checking
the value on my i have a cheap compass
i've been paying off for a long time the
payment was 600 a month
for a while because i brought over
negative equity
i got that
drawn out longer to lower the payment so
i could
pay more off
that vehicle
has issues it's been fixed since but i
had to get another vehicle when i did
that so i have two vehicles on loan
so my thought process was i'm only about
two grand off from what the
dealer will give me
for the vehicle and paying it off
totally so
i'm currently i'm on unemployment this
is the first time i've been unemployed
in my life
so
i'm going to start door dashing right
now until i find something else
to
[Music]
be more steady in income she makes about
20 000 a year right now 1700 a month she
works as a
and housekeeping how old are you
i'm 26. cool
welcome to the show brother yeah so what
were you doing before before you were
unemployed
um well for a long time i was working uh
in the prison systems making decent
money but not making
good financial decisions so you know i
have a lot of stuff but i don't have a
lot to you know i mean i don't have a
lot to show for it yeah and uh
well your a1
i want you to get income in the door and
that might mean doing door dash
instacart ship maybe you do them all do
whatever you can right now until you can
get a full-time salaried position or
something where you have some more
stable income coming in and what we
teach here is the baby steps i know
you're a new listener and so what we're
going to do is do you have a thousand
dollars in cash right now in savings no
no so that's your a1 that's your first
goal and get rid of that stupid car you
said you got the extra car you have two
cars right now both have loans on it
yeah could you sell both and get a
crappy car right now while you clean up
this mess
yeah that's what i i originally planned
on trying to get rid of the jeep no
matter what but i've been watching all
day and just thinking
and what do you owe on the other car
the other so i owe so i have 17 000
roughly on the the jeep and i can get
what do you owe on the other car
the other car oh 14. yeah
okay get you a five thousand dollar car
i just got the other one i don't know
though so i think i can get
a good value out of it
good yeah i don't care because here's
the thing these things are if you didn't
have these two car payments you'd have
like what's known as a life
yeah i'd have a lot of money left over
yeah and you could go get the job and
you start cooking cooking with gas then
you could get this thing moving and walk
right up those baby steps yeah here's
what i'm gonna do kelly's gonna pick up
we're gonna send you a copy of the total
money makeover since you're new to the
show read through that get really
intense about this man and call us back
when you're debt free